this video is about Empirical research
what is Empirical research and what is
the difference between qualitative and
quantitative we'll go over that in this
video
let's start with the first question what
does empirical mean empirical derives
from the Greek empiria and means
experience or observation
empirical knowledge can therefore be
seen as experimental knowledge but what
is the goal of Empirical research
the goal of Imperial research is to
collect experience about reality and or
to test experience about reality the
first area is usually the task of
qualitative research the second area is
the task of quantitative research
we've already learned two things first
that Empirical research is about gaining
or testing knowledge about reality
second that Empirical research is
divided into qualitative research and
quantitative research an example
let's say you're interested in the topic
how do people in Vienna deal with
increased inflation this is an open
question and you decide to address the
issue qualitatively
to answer this question you conduct
interviews with people from Vienna the
results of the interview show that all
the people in Vienna take more savings
measures than younger people that is the
experience or observation you're making
from this you could derive the following
hypothesis all the people in Vienna take
more savings measures due to increased
inflation than younger people you can
now test this hypothesis in a
quantitative study for this you first
think about how to make savings measures
measurable
then you create a standardized
questionnaire in which you ask among
other things the age of the respondents
and the extent of savings measures now
you can use a hypothesis test to test
whether there is a significant positive
correlation between age and the extent
of savings measures
if that was the case you would have an
indication that in Vienna H has a
positive influence on the extent of
savings measures
but what exactly is the difference
between qualitative and quantitative in
most cases we want to use qualitative
research to develop hypotheses and
quantitative research to test hypotheses
of course a quantitative study can also
be descriptive or exploratory
in this case you would not test
hypotheses
since we want to develop hypotheses in
qualitative research it is of course not
necessary to formulate hypotheses in
advance the goal is to come up with new
ideas and develop new hypotheses based
on collected data
therefore qualitative research is well
suited for so far unknown fields of
research in quantitative research on the
other hand we want to test hypotheses so
of course we need to formulate these
hypotheses in advance
since these hypotheses do not come out
of nowhere we must first conduct a
Thrive literature review the goal is to
test the hypotheses using collected data
thus quantitative research is suited for
well-known research areas where
literature already exists
therefore if a topic is still very
unexplored and an understanding of the
problem or theories need to be developed
then this is the task of qualitative
research
theories are formulated the series are
then tested this is the task of
quantitative research theories are
tested
what about data collection in
qualitative and quantitative studies in
both cases in qualitative and in
quantitative research you need data to
address your research topic
however the two areas differ in data
collection and in the form in which they
are obtained in a qualitative study for
example you use interviews or
observations to get your data the data
you then receive is so-called Soft Data
such as text images or videos
for example if you have contacted
interviews with people recorded them and
written them down respectively
transcribe them then your data is
available in text form
in a quantitative study on the other
hand you use for example a survey or an
experiment
the day that you receive is so-called
hard data or numerical data the data
obtained can then be analyzed using
statistical methods according to clear
rules
if you have conducted an online survey
for example you will receive your data
in a structured form
each row is a respondent every column is
a question and each cell takes a unique
value
here for example you asked about gender
salary and age
the first person is for example female
and has an income of 1 500 euros
therefore in a qualitative study the
data is collected in an open format in a
quantitative study the data is collected
in a standardized format
let's look at this with an example
for example in your qualitative work you
ask the participants in your study the
following question when you think about
your health how would you describe it
right now
you ask an open question and the answer
from each respondent will most likely
differ
one answer could be I'm not doing well
at all my chop stresses me out so much
that I can't sleep at night and I'm sick
all the time
how does it look in the quantitative
case
in the quantitative case you would
standardize your questions for example
you would ask how healthy do you feel at
the moment not healthy at all rather not
healthy medium rather healthy very
healthy so you would provide specific
answer options
what does the research process look like
in a qualitative and the quantitative
thesis
in qualitative research we have a
circular research process the workflows
are less structured and can be designed
flexibly loops and returns to previous
steps are possible
in quantitative research we have a
linear research process there's a
well-structured process with clearly
defined steps loops and returns to
previous steps are mostly not possible
or not usual
there's also a difference between
qualitative and quantitative research in
the selection of research participants
in qualitative research you tend to have
a small sample
few individuals are studied and the goal
is to look very closely at each
individual subject
in quantitative research you tend to
have a large sample in a quantitative
case the goal is to make a generalized
statement about the population
furthermore in a qualitative thesis the
sample size is open and it can be
adjusted in the course of the study
in a quantitative thesis the sample size
is determined before the study starts
now a brief summary of the differences
between qualitative and quantitative
qualitative versus quantitative
hypotheses qualitative mostly developing
hypotheses and quantitative mostly
hypothesis testing
data collection qualitative open with
for example interviews or observations
and quantitative
standardized with for example service or
experiments
research process qualitative secular and
quantitative linear
and finally sample size rather small in
qualitative case rather large in the
quantitative case
and now we continue with the video on
quantitative research then we go through
the entire research process of a
quantitative thesis thanks for watching